certainly don't try to suck out venom
because that's never really been shown
to improve the outcome of any snake bite
i'm dr cyrus rangan i'm a medical
toxicologist with the california poison
control system where i've been assistant
medical director for the past 20 years
today we'll be looking at toxicology
scenes in movies and judging how real
they are
what it looks like is that he has a
false tooth that actually contains uh
cyanide the concept of actually hiding
cyanide in a false tooth uh seems to be
a little bit more folklore than it is
fact and in fact uh when you when you
talk to people at the at the national
spy museum they'll tell you that this is
not something that people really engaged
in but did uh villains uh maybe back in
in you know the time of nazi germany
things like that did they use cyanide
capsules to commit suicide so that they
would not be incriminated later yes that
that practice actually did occur there
still are some problems with this the
concept of the foaming uh followed very
quickly by death is probably more
theatrical than it is uh expected
symptoms that you would see from a
scientific standpoint is it possible
that someone might have some excessive
drooling or foaming while they're
experiencing other symptoms of cyanide
poisoning sure that's possible but for
that to be the only symptom and then so
quickly followed by death that's what
gets a little bit farfetched here
cyanide although it is a relatively
fast-acting poison meaning it doesn't
take hours to kill you it still does
take a few minutes at least and perhaps
in that five to ten minute period that's
when death generally is seen i could
give this somewhere between maybe a
three or a four i think he is the
cleverest man i know
clever enough to learn what poison you
use to murder
myself long goodbye was that it the long
farewell that's the one obviously we are
not aware as toxicologists of any poison
that is even nicknamed the long farewell
uh so it sounds like it's entirely made
up
how long does the poison take
difficult to say hours days it depends
on the subject's constitution but death
is certain oh yes
quite sad if we are to go with his uh
assessment that this could take several
hours or perhaps days to kill you there
are some toxins out in the world that
could act like that and the one that
comes to mind is uh the disease botulism
and botulism is a disease that does work
relatively slowly from that standpoint
[Music]
the concept of putting it on somebody's
lips and kissing that person and then
being able to neutralize that with some
kind of kind of an oral antidote is a
little bit far-fetched when it comes to
poisons and antidotes or anti-toxins it
really depends on the poison itself in
terms of whether there is an anti-toxin
or antidote available it's not common
that we would have a very deadly poison
that you could take immediately and then
give an antidote immediately orally that
is suddenly going to neutralize that
poison and limit its ability to kill you
if it's something that would kill you
otherwise for this one i would probably
put it in the range of about two to
three
i smell nothing
what you do not smell is called iokin
powder it is odorless tasteless
dissolves instantly in liquid and is
among the more deadly poisons known to
man for
wesley to say that it dissolves
instantly in any liquid is also a little
bit far-fetched because for example
things that dissolve well in water don't
dissolve well in alcohol and vice versa
so to say that it dissolves in any
liquid
is something that probably goes beyond
the realm of science
[Music]
we're talking about a poison here that
kills someone very very quickly and
there aren't really many poisons that
can do that that can kill you within
seconds where you look just fine and
then suddenly die
i spent the last few years building up
an immunity to iocan powder in general
when we're talking about poisons these
aren't things that you can really build
up an immunity towards you can build up
immunity towards infectious diseases but
building up an immunity towards a poison
is not something that we generally see
there is a concept that's called
tolerance so for example with drug users
they tend to require higher and higher
doses of whatever drug of choice they
use in order to achieve their desired
effect and that's a different kind of
concept but the concept of immunity from
a poison is not something that we would
uh consider scientific i would probably
give it a three
peter
that's night lock peter you'll be dead
in a minute
i didn't know so night lock is is is
fictional as far as the name is
concerned and probably is derived from
from nightshade and perhaps they are
combining it with hemlock which is
another poison but when you look at
those particular berries those look like
what are called atropa belladonna uh
berries which is uh commonly referred to
as deadly nightshade where you could get
dizzy kind of confused a little bit
loopy and possibly unresponsive and
sometimes patients can be so severe that
they get seizures and coma and if you're
going to die from deadly nightshade that
would be the reason where it does fall
apart a little bit for me is when she
says that it will kill you in a minute
the bottom line is that you should never
ever ever do your own foraging unless
you are a botanist and someone who's
well trained and i'd probably put it
about around a four
when i was a kid whenever we went hiking
we always carried oliver an eraser blade
in case of a snake bites
the depiction of this particular snake
bite wound looked a little bit unusual
to me usually a snake bite is a
subcutaneous injury where the fangs
make it down into the
tissue at or below the skin layer and
then you start to get a lot of
destruction of the tissue around that
area and a lot of inflammation and
subsequent swelling so you don't expect
to see that that sort of voluminous bag
of fluid
[Music]
what we have learned however over the
last uh several decades is that cutting
into a snakebite wound is probably a
very bad thing to do and we've seen many
cases where people actually introduce
more injury into the situation
than than then help the situation so
people are cutting into arteries and
veins cutting into nerves cutting into
tendons so these are are very bad things
that can happen as a result of slicing
into that wound so in general we don't
slice into snakebite wounds
good boy and we certainly don't try to
suck out venom because that's never
really been shown to improve the outcome
of any snake bite in medieval times
people
back then said that you should coat your
lips with olive oil and open the wound
and suck out the the venom and again
this was back from medieval times but
unfortunately a lot of those kinds of
treatments especially for envenomations
carried over through the centuries the
general rule of thumb for any snake bite
is simply to get to a hospital as soon
as humanly possible uh there really is
no other first aid that you really need
to do other than to keep the patient
calm so you can be evaluated and
evaluated for the need for anti-venom
and i would actually rate the accuracy
at quite low somewhere between zero and
one and simply because they are talking
about treatments that could really make
a bad situation worse
castor beans
so what are we gonna do with them
oh you're going to process them into
ricin ricin of course is a real toxin
and we derive from natural sources it
actually comes from the castor bean or
the castor seed when you're ingesting
ricin it causes mayhem in your
gastrointestinal tract so what's going
to happen is you're going to experience
extremely voluminous fluid loss and it
can be so uh severe that it it's
impossible to catch up by just simply
drinking and trying to replace those
fluids and can it cause death yes it can
from all those fluid losses it's toxic
in small doses also fairly easy to
overlook during an autopsy and that's
probably true that if someone was
experiencing
extreme vomiting and diarrhea and and
dehydration and then death
ricin is not necessarily the first thing
that people would think of people would
think more about infectious diseases uh
causing those kinds of problems kind of
under the weather
like you've got the flu
that would be the ricin i gave you
there is no direct antidote for ricin
it's really the treatment is what we
call in medicine supportive care so in
other words we treat the bad symptoms
that occur uh from the the actual
poisoning itself you know she was
on the phone and conscious and and you
know so if she was experiencing symptoms
she probably was in the very early phase
so she probably could get herself to a
hospital and maybe get ahead of the
poisoning by making sure that she's got
iv fluids on board as soon as possible
before the severe symptoms took place
yeah it's entirely possible that he's
giving it away a little bit too early
for her so that she could potentially
get treatment and survive as far as the
scientific accuracy i would give this an
8.
it begins of course with uh with bond
drinking a poison from his glass what uh
we learned later is that this poison was
digitalis now digitalis is a real uh
poison it's a real compound but
digitalis itself is available in a
number of different plants so there's a
plant called foxglove another one called
lily of the valley it's actually a
medication and it helps the heart uh
pump more efficiently and when given
under medical supervision under uh
precise circumstances and we're checking
drug levels it's a it's a reasonable
thing to do for patients however in in
large doses digitalis and other related
compounds
can cause severe poisoning some poisons
can
cause some major symptoms with just a
very very small dose uh digitalis
probably would not be one of them i
would not expect digitalis in the form
of a couple of drops in a martini glass
uh and then after that is then you know
distributed throughout the rest of the
glass and then a couple of sips later
you're suddenly experiencing digitalis
poisoning that's a little bit
far-fetched
[Music]
and while it is true that if you instill
a concentrated salt solution into your
stomach very rapidly it will likely make
you vomit making somebody vomit after
taking a poison into the stomach is
actually not well supported
scientifically so this is not really a
practice that we espouse anymore so
that's something where he was probably
really wasting his time von's been
poisoned he's going into cardiac arrest
stay calm ventricular tachycardia
digitized so now they've identified the
toxin in in record time now that is a
real term and that's a term referred to
the lower chambers of the heart
uncontrollably beating very very fast
and that is something that does require
immediate treatment one thing that i
could say that they represented more or
less uh effectively was the uh feelings
that he was having the symptoms that he
was having so it sounds like he was
having a you know a pounding feeling in
his chest and some nausea and he's
sweating those are the kinds of symptoms
that you might expect from digitalis
poisoning
take the blue combi pen bond mid neck
into the vein
counteract the digit
they have him inject something into his
neck the term comedy pen is something
that that is it's a simply made-up word
i'm just hazarding a guess that
lidocaine is what they use because that
is something you can uh inject into
people who have ventricular tachycardia
from a poisoning but as i mentioned
before it's got to be given under very
well supervised circumstances
i'll get yourself off to hospital
and we'll do
as soon as i won this game if you have
any poison on board that's causing an
abnormal heart rhythm um yeah you want
to restore the heart rhythm back to
normal but that doesn't cure you of the
poison but what he actually needs is the
real treatment for digitalis which is
digitalis specific antibodies and that
actually is the first line treatment
it is a little bit uh unbelievable that
he's not rushing to a hospital right now
to get that uh that key treatment that
he actually needs probably give this
about a 3.
there's really only one thing you can do
what what is it you're going to have to
pee on it what i think they really did
get right is the fact that jellyfish
stings tend to impart immediate pain and
it's quite severe for a lot of people as
well depending on how much of the
jellyfish tentacle got got on you where
i think it falls apart is when it comes
to the treatment it's long been folklore
that you should urinate on a jellyfish
sting there is no scientific backing to
it you simply use the sea water to wash
off any remnants of those tentacles that
may still be on the site those remnants
include tiny little cell-like
bags called pneumatocysts if they remain
on your skin they can still discharge
and so we like to use salt water
essentially to cleanse those off gently
so urine has the potential to be able to
accomplish that too you're better off
just using the sea water than peeing on
yourself if you put fresh water onto a
jellyfish sting where those
pneumatocysts are still on your skin
they can discharge under conditions of
fresh water so if your urine perhaps is
too dilute at that moment you could
actually discharge those pneumatocysts
and cause more pain in a lot of cases
urinating on yourself probably won't
make things too bad for you it probably
won't help but in certain situations it
could make things worse uh this is not a
good illustration about what to do
afterwards i would uh give this a a
round to
the six is affecting your nervous system
stay even an insect sting or insect bite
that could result in uh the depression
of the central nervous system that's
probably not gonna happen from from most
things uh in this sort of immediate uh
fashion that we're seeing here within
seconds or within minutes there is
actually a disease called tick paralysis
where there's a certain kind of tick a
hard back tick that actually has a
neurotoxic venom that's injected into
very very tiny amounts into us but can
actually cause full-body paralysis but
the take has to latch on to you and stay
there for several hours perhaps even a
day so there is that real uh possibility
that yes an insect could give you
paralysis
would it happen this quickly i don't
think so inject yourself directly into
your heart with the first stage do it
now
we give the liberty that this is a
science fiction movie and that there is
some uh fictional super bug out there
that is causing this uh paralysis um but
would we um have a situation where we
thought a neurotoxin injected from a bug
would need to be treated by an injection
into the heart that's where things fall
apart for me as well if you had for
example an allergic reaction to let's
say a bee sting you could still also
give intravenous epinephrine by putting
it into a vein but if you didn't have
that access you didn't have the ability
to set that up and your
you know time's ticking away you can
make the argument that you could give an
epinephrine shot directly into the heart
and that actually is the initial
treatment we would give for nerve agent
exposure it would be atropine directly
into the heart so yes there is an
argument to be made for intracardiac
injections of certain medications in
very specific circumstances but
certainly not for an envenomation i'd
probably put this in the range of about
zero to one i'd say the one that's most
scientifically accurate was the one from
breaking bad they used the good correct
terminology and uh gave an illustration
of what is supposed to happen to a
person under these circumstances the
most fun to watch i think was princess
bride as i think
if you enjoyed this video click the link
above for another